what's an ice resurfacing machine
sound like and can you give us the
impression what it sounds like the
Zamboni I don't even know what sound like
Zamboni I'm always in the locker room some going
on what does his emo sound [Music] like uh [Music]
[Music] I like that sounds more like a [Music]
[Laughter]
cow well you laugh it up Joe what would
your sound like you dude the Zamboni like
[Music]
[Music] a that's the the pump the water down
and then the sweepers on the side of the
boards that's what I got for [Music]
you an ice surfacing machine like a
zambo no I I'm just trying to think of
the sound it's not much of a sound it's
[Music]
like
zambon zambon
Zamboni that's probably what I would
have what even was that that
yeah
for